in this video i'm going to show you my
thought process in choosing the right
laptop that suits my needs both as an
architect and as a content creator the
goal of this video is to pass on all of
the knowledge that i learned about
choosing a laptop so that you can choose
the right laptop for you
whether you're a student or an architect
or a creative professional at the end of
this video i'm gonna go through some of
my recommendations and give you a list
of models that i think you should take
into consideration this is gonna be
another long video so grab a cup of tea
and let's get started a portion of this
video is sponsored by aura more on them
later in this video
[Music]
the first question you should ask
yourself is why do you need a laptop and
not a workstation what helped me make my
decision is the following statement a
laptop can be a workstation but a
workstation cannot be a laptop let that
sink in working as an architect i
currently outsource most of my
renderings or i use cloud-based services
so i don't really need the full force of
power that i can get from a workstation
and as a content creator i need a device
that's both portable and powerful and
since laptops became much better at
rendering tasks than even just a couple
of years ago thanks to the gpu and
software optimization choosing a laptop
over a workstation was a pretty obvious
choice for me
at the beginning of your career you're
not gonna know anything
you're gonna be so brand new and
probably it's gonna be a little bit
shocking for you
you're not gonna know how to work with
clients or consultants or do
construction
and they're gonna have to teach you all
of that
so when you started a firm
one of your superpowers is going to be
visualization and software skills which
is why you want to be able to try out
and learn a variety of different
industry standard apps
and as a young architect your software
knowledge is going to give you that
competitive advantage and it's going to
increase your chances of getting hired
at a firm and when you start at the firm
companies are either going to give you a
laptop
which in most cases means they're going
to outsource the final renderings or use
a cloud-based rendering service or
they're going to give you a desk with a
workstation which means some of the
renderings will probably be done
internally or they're going to give you
both a laptop and a workstation and this
is becoming more and more common
especially after the pandemic where
offices are getting more and more lacks
about remote work another thing to
consider is
if you plan on moonlighting or working
on side projects while working at your
firm
having a powerful personal laptop will
come in really handy
these are the three most common form
factors for laptops mobility isn't
always the only reason why you need a
laptop in fact a lot of people use
laptops because they live in small
apartments where having a workstation or
a dedicated computer could be an issue
if you're a student chances are you're
spending most of your day in studio or
at the library or working from home
with reliable access to power outlets so
having a small laptop with a really good
battery life might not really be a
priority for you what is probably more
important is a good screen
and good processing power the market
just has so many options right now that
if you're willing to put up with a
slightly thicker laptop you can get a
huge boost in performance and just a lot
more options that you can choose from
and in some cases you can even save some
money as an architect i need to be able
to work in different locations and have
something that's easy to take around so
portability is definitely a factor for
me i have a m1 air and m1 pro
and
honestly i'm so impressed with the
overall build and quality and the
battery life has been just incredible
macbooks have aluminum bodies that
always feels solid and look very
professional thanks to my youtube gig i
also have an hp x360 transformable
laptop that i use for sketching and
note-taking this one's probably the most
versatile laptop that i have and i'll go
through some of the features later on in
this video speaking about useful tools i
want to talk about today's sponsor aura
identity theft is no joke it actually
happened to me and it was probably one
of the worst experiences i've ever had
losing control of your personal
information money and time is something
that no one should experience i've been
really strict on my privacy and since
then i've avoided sharing personal
information but i simply can't monitor
everything myself hackers only need you
to be distracted one single time and
apparently i'm not alone identity theft
is one of the fastest growing crimes in
america there's a new victim every 14
seconds using aura is like wearing an
invisible armor that gives you multiple
layers of protection including fraud
monitoring vpn identity theft protection
antivirus password management app aura
will scan the dark web for your emails
passwords and social security number and
if there's a match they're gonna send an
alert directly to your phone and email
basically it gives you a chance to stop
a crime before it happens if you use the
link in the description you're gonna
have access to a two-week trial and you
can be protected right away stopping
hackers before they get their eyes on
your data is the only way to stay
protected and i would really recommend
checking it out
and this was something that i actually
never consciously thought of before but
since getting the macbook air m1 which
of course at the time was one of the
first laptops with
great processing power and no active
cooling i think this makes a pretty big
difference when i'm presenting in small
rooms or when i'm working in a space
with other noisy laptops and i wouldn't
say it's a serious issue but it's
definitely noticeable and it can get
kind of annoying over time if this is
something you're concerned about you
should consider a laptop with a passive
cooling system which are typically
thinner and more portable but they're
not as powerful or they cost a little
bit more money
in terms of screen size you might think
bigger is better
but in my case
even though having a big screen with a
large resolution is nice when i'm
sitting down for work i mostly use my
laptop with an external monitor both at
work and at my home office gaming
laptops are more focused on performance
and in most cases the resolution and
quality of the screen don't really go
beyond full hd
especially if you're on a budget for
color reproduction these are some of the
standards you can look at the coverage
of the standard is measured in
percentage and the higher the percentage
the better the ability of the display to
reproduce these standards if you're
looking for a laptop with a really good
display i would recommend the last
generation of macbooks and you can just
feel more confident about the color
reproduction if you're not going to rely
on the laptop display for the color
accuracy it is relatively easy to find
an affordable color calibrated external
monitor these days as an external
monitor i use the lg dual up which is
definitely unconventional in terms of
resolution but it packs a lot of
features for the price if you want to
know more about it i'm going to leave
the link right here
i tried standard laptops and transformed
laptops and i realized that i definitely
prefer having a dedicated device for
specific functions rather than having a
multi-functional laptop for example for
sketching i almost always use my ipad
pro because i found the size of a
transformable laptop a little bit too
big to carry around especially if you're
not working on a desk or a working
surface i also really like the ability
to sketch while multitasking or doing
other work and sometimes i just need to
be able to draw things really quickly
and pull them out on the spot to show
people so having an independent device
it just makes more sense for me but if
you're student and you're on a budget
and you want to hit two birds with one
stone you should probably take the two
in one device into account i actually
created a video that shows my procreate
workflow with the ipad pro and i also
did an in-depth review of the hp spectre
x360 i'll leave the link to both right
here
i'm always pushing for more ports on
laptops and since i work with a ton of
hard drives and monitors and other
devices i really really need to rely on
the usbc hubs for connectivity and
that's why i'm a really big fan of the
lg dole up because it takes full
advantage of the usbc connection with
one cable you can do like three things
at the same time and you can power a
laptop up to 90 watts and connect it to
a monitor and have access to two usb
devices at the same time i actually
don't even need to bring a charger and i
can save space in my backpack i just log
into my laptop and voila you get a fully
functional workstation i just got so
used to the fast wake up time and the
long battery life of my m1 and also
having the fingerprint scanner
integrated into laptop it just makes it
really easy to just log in from session
to session
the architecture industry is still
heavily based on windows and so far none
of the offices that i've worked at have
used apple computers and i think this is
especially true with medium to large
firms but the arm processor by apple are
really great in terms of performance per
watt the list of native apps is always
growing
and for content creation i honestly feel
like they already have a pretty solid
list of apps revit which is one of the
industry standard bim software still
works only on windows platforms you can
use parallels or other windows emulation
apps to run it on a mac but most firms
they tend to stick with windows because
they don't really want to deal with the
compatibility issues or having lower
performance i've seen some companies use
archicad and vectorworks on macs
especially if you're doing smaller
buildings like houses or renaults
because smaller size projects they don't
require as much coordination with your
team or between different disciplines
so you know i'm not gonna do any
benchmarks in my videos since you can
find plenty online by just doing a quick
google search having said that most of
the architecture software still relies
heavily on the cpu for a lot of tasks
and in terms of pure performance intel
is leading the way for now
i'd say 16 gigabytes of ram is the bare
minimum for architecture design or
content creation work but with 32
gigabytes you will be working
comfortably without too many compromises
when i got my m1 air laptop two years
ago i was a little bit disappointed that
the max ram size i could get was only 16
gigabytes
but with the new m2 processor apple's
finally added a 24 gigabyte option as
well as a dedicated charging port so
yeah with max you can't upgrade the ram
so you just need to know what size you
want when you're buying it but with a
lot of gaming laptops they let you
upgrade the ram size and they also give
you really easy access to an additional
ssd slot on my gaming laptop yes i had a
gaming laptop i had two very fast
internal ssds one for the os and one as
a scratch disk architecture and creative
software they need to generate a lot of
temporary files or cache files to work
properly which is why your system disk
space shrinks over time so you do need
to do some routine cleaning for it to
function well a scratch disk is an
internal ssd drive that solves a lot of
these issues instead of letting the apps
save all of their cash in the system
drive i redirect all of them to go into
the scratch drive and this can really
speed up your rendering time it can also
avoid bandwidth bottlenecks and it makes
the previews more responsive and it
saves a ton of space on your main drive
the only drawback is that it will
consume more power so it can affect the
battery life of your laptop
architecture software and visualization
software have a really symbiotic
relationship with the gpu real-time
renders like enscape lumion and unreal
engine 5 can now generate global
illumination and photo realism via
real-time ray tracing and the
architecture industry's also really
taken advantage of these new tools today
rendering a full quality frame could
only take a couple of seconds and you
can do it directly in the viewport
window and also adobe creative cloud
resolve and some of the other apps can
also get a performance boost from modern
gpus for all of these reasons a
dedicated graphics card is highly
recommended in architecture and
rendering work to see which one performs
better there are plenty of benchmarks
around i'm going to leave some of the
links in the description if you want to
take a look but i think for architecture
and rendering work getting a laptop with
a dedicated graphics card is the way to
go
for architecture work my company gave me
the latest version of the dell xps
15-inch with an intel processor and a
geforce 3050. this machine is really a
jack of all trades and it performs
really well in rendering tasks as well
as video editing tasks i have the
version with the 4k display and it
retails for around 2400
for my personal content creation work
which is mostly writing some video
editing and photo editing i use a
macbook pro m1 and as i mentioned before
macbooks with the m1 or m2 processors
have amazing display incredible battery
life and build and they really excel
when the apps take full advantage of the
arm architecture however
i do know that these are really
expensive and if you're a student you're
probably looking for the best bang for
your buck so you should also consider
gaming laptops like the latest asus
tough 15 or 17. i use a tough gaming
laptop for a really long time and you
can see from the specs these really are
ticking all of the boxes in terms of
performance as long as you can sacrifice
the portability and the battery life and
of course it is pretty loud in the
active cooling department these are the
ones that i've had personal experience
with but of course there's a lot of
options you can choose from
some brands are even starting to come up
with some really cool and unconventional
designs
like adding multiple displays or
transformable features
and some of them are really pushing the
boundaries of what a laptop could be
like the new asus zenfold 17 which can
literally fold into a tablet so try not
to get tricked by flashy marketing
understanding who you are and how you
work is the most important factor in
making the right purchase all right
that's it guys
i hope that was helpful and good luck
finding your laptop and let me know in
the comments what's your favorite laptop
if you want to explore outside of tech
and if you're interested in architecture
and design and creativity i'll leave a
playlist at the end of this video if you
found this video helpful please like and
subscribe it really helps out the
channel and with that i'll see you guys
on the next one
[Music]
you